[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ich kann eigentlich
niemanden der ihn nicht mag den
amerikanischen krautsalat besser bekannt
als kind taktiken kosler denn ich glaube
darüber kennt ihn einfach jeder und ich
finde wenn man weiß wie einfach der
eigentlich nach zu machen ist dann muss
man hier noch gar nicht mehr kaufen an
zutaten benötigen wir einen kleinen bis
mittelgroßen kohlkopf außerdem noch zwei
rote zwiebeln vier möhren und für das
dressing 500 gramm salat mayonnaise 70
gramm puderzucker tatsächlich 50
milliliter streit einen halben teelöffel
pfeffer einen gestrichenen teelöffel
salz und ein esslöffel essig zuallererst
wird das gemüse vorbereitet und hierfür
nehme ich mir erst mal den weißkohl und
schneide ihn dann in ganz dünne streifen
und die streifen teile ich anschließend
noch durch drei
[Musik]
die roten zwiebeln schneide ich noch in
kleine würfel
ihr könntet auch normale zwiebeln nehmen
aber die roten schmecken einfach ein
wenig feiner
[Musik]
die möhren habe ich geschält und
anschließend werden sie fein geraspelt
[Musik]
die drei gemüsesorten werden jetzt in
einer ausreichend großen schüssel
ordentlich vermischt und dann geht es
weiter mit dem leckeren dressing in
einer separaten schüsse wird die
mayonnaise zusammen mit der streit mit
einem schneebesen gut verrührt und falls
ihr euch fragt warum wir ausgerechnet
streit benutzen das macht den geschmack
einfach unverwechselbar und typisch
amerikanisch sobald sich die zwei
zutaten gut miteinander verbunden haben
kommt der puderzucker mit hinzu und wir
nehmen hier kein raffinierten zucker den
puderzucker lässt sich hier viel besser
auflösen
nachdem dann auch der puderzucker
klümpchen frei verrührt wurde kommt noch
dass es sich mit hinzu wird ganz kurz
untergerührt und dann wird gewürzt mit
salz und pfeffer
[Musik]
so schnell und unkompliziert gegen die
zubereitung des dressings das einzige
was wir jetzt noch tun müssen ist das
dressing auf den salat zu geben und gut
miteinander zu verrühren
[Musik]
wer mag kann den salat jetzt noch eine
stunde lang ziehen lassen das muss aber
nicht sein er ist sofort sehr wohl
bereit und falls jetzt noch daneben
meine kind taci hot wings servieren
möchtet dann klickt auf jeden fall auf
das video und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß beim nachmachen und falls ihr
keines meiner videos mehr verpassen
möchte dann freue ich mich sehr über
euer aber bis zum nächsten mal auf die
skis kitchen
[Musik]